So just this morning I was reading an article about a biblical document or an
allegedly
biblical document
that was
about
1500 to
2000 years old and this document is called the epistle of Barnabas.
Now the article said that this epistle claimed
that Jesus never
actually resurrected.
In fact,
Jesus was just simply a prophet that Jesus ascended to heaven without dying and then
Judas
Iscariot was actually crucified in Jesus's place.
Now if you've ever read this book,
then you know none of those things are in this book the way I've just described
them.
But here is an article that says that this is true and like, oh,
this is this astounding new information that we have about Jesus.
But as Christians, we know that this book, a
Bible, is what tells us the truth of Christianity.
Which kind of raises an interesting question. How do I know this document is true?
And that's what this whole
series of unit or this whole unit is about.
All these lessons are going to walk you through.
How do we know the Bible is true? How do we know that it's accurate?
How do we know that it's reliable and authoritative?
See,
the problem is that often what we do is we get stuck into this loop where we ask the
question of how
do I know that the Bible is true, okay?
Well, then we say, well, that's because
the Bible says so.
Well, how do I know that the Bible says so?
Well, because I know the Bible's true
and we just keep going in a circle over and over and over again,
and we never actually have anything
exterior that helps us understand whether or not the Bible is actually true.
We throw in there a little bit of, well, it's the inspired,
I can't write, inspired word of God.
And therefore it must be true and it must be because the Bible says so,
because it's the inspired word of God,
because we know it's true and we go on and on that way.
How do I know beyond all of those things that this is true?
How do I know that it's authoritative?
How do I know that what's in these pages are actually going to teach me on how to
live the life that God has
designed for me?
And that's what students need to know and that's what we're going to explore.
In this first week,
we're going to talk about texts and is this text specifically the New Testament,
is the New Testament text.
No, last week,
we ended talking about Jesus and all that Jesus said and all that Jesus claimed to
be
and the resurrection, all this stuff about Jesus.
How do I know that what's in here about Jesus in the New Testament is accurate?
Well,
what's fascinating about that is that we have what's called an autograph and a
manuscript.
Now, an autograph is an original copy.
OK, an autograph is as if I actually gave my autograph, my signature.
It's original to me.
I wrote it and only I can write it.
That's essentially what we're talking about when we say an autograph.
When we talk about texts from antiquity, the ancient text, those biblical times
and earlier and all around that era, we have no autographs.
We have nothing originally written by anybody in their physical hand.
OK, but what we do have is manuscripts, copies.
Sometimes there are copies of a copy of a copy that is entirely possible.
So the question we have to answer in this first lesson is do we have enough
manuscripts and do we have enough manuscripts that are accurate
across all of the copies to say that what's in here in my hand is an accurate
representation of what Paul wrote, what Jesus said, what Peter wrote
and what actually happened during the days of Jesus.
So to start this process, we ask students in the introduction activity
to look up a legal document that proves their existence.
So think about you have a birth certificate, you have a driver's license,
you can't get on an airplane without a driver's license or a passport.
You're often asked for your Social Security card anytime your identity
is checked for a job or that kind of a thing, right?
So you have to have some kind of proof of your existence that you are who
you say you are.
So we have these legal binding documents that are proof of something.
So we want students to start to see that there are documents out there even
today that have this kind of power.
All right, so I want you to think about your students' textbooks in school,
especially the ones that talk about ancient literature.
So think of like a world history textbook that's going to talk about
the details of the ancient Roman Empire, Alexander the Great and some
of the great armies and the movement of barbarian tribes,
those kinds of things that sort of help shape the history of the modern world,
all of the things that your students learn and really consider to be actual fact,
right? So all of those things are derived from historical texts and derived
from different things that give us clues into understanding
what happened in history.
So for instance, you have things like natural history by a historian named Pliny.
Now, this guy was a Roman historian and most of what he wrote about had to do
with agricultural and business and economics and those kinds of things.
But it gives us great insight into what Rome was like and how to understand
the Roman Empire and some of the insights that we have into their world
and their technology as an ancient culture.
All right. So we have not a ton of copies.
OK, so estimated we have roughly
100 or so, maybe less, maybe more of something like that.
Now, those are copies over a copy over a copy.
Different languages sometimes are scattered throughout different places,
those kinds of things.
Now, how much of the New Testament do we have?
Right? How much of the actual New Testament?
Now, this isn't full Bibles.
I don't want you to think like this is like a bunch of actual like full Bible
copies.
Sometimes they're just little pieces, little fragments,
little things that we got a place together.
Sometimes they're full books.
Sometimes they're multiple books together.
But oftentimes these are scattered all throughout the region from the east
to the west and they're found in all kinds of different place or times.
Right? So we have if you put all of that together,
roughly in excess of six thousand copies of of just the New Testament.
Now, if you put a whole bunch of other things together,
you're talking in excess of 20,000 different copies.
That's a lot of copies.
Now, what happens if you say, well, how accurate are these copies?
Because that's going to help understand how accurate this is.
If you put all the copies together,
everything across the board is in excess of 95 percent the same.
And that three to five percent is like words like the and a and things that may
have been missing or may have taken out, but none of it affects theology.
Now, that's pretty astounding.
And in your leader guy, we're giving you resources to find out some more detailed
and exact numbers. I would encourage you to check those out.
Josh McDowell has actually just updated some of those numbers.
And some of these have even gotten better and better over the last couple of years.
So I would encourage you to check those out and share those numbers with your
students, because it's it's it's almost mind bending to think that the New
Testament, as it is here, is actually more reliable and more historical
than some of the stuff that's in the textbooks that your students are reading,
learning in school as fact.
Now, I'm not saying those aren't fact,
but how much more is the New Testament reliable than some of the world
history books that we have in schools say it's a lot more reliable.
This is huge, right?
So I do want to make one comment about the misconception and illumination,
because what we've done here is slightly different than what we've done in the past.
Before the misconception was often a verse or a comment that was
misunderstood frequently by students, and we wanted to point them in a direction
that corrects them, but also illuminates their understanding further.
This year, what we did is we wanted to pull out some information from some
other authors, some notable atheists and some people that don't agree
with what Christianity teaches.
So you'll notice very specifically this week we have Bart Ehrman is a New
Testament critic, agnostic, probably was a Christian, understands the Bible very,
very well, but writes specifically against what the Bible teaches and that the
Bible is not accurate.
And he says that we have only error-ridden copies and the vast
majority of these are centuries removed from the originals and different
from them, evidently in thousands of ways.
Well, what's fascinating about that is that Bart Ehrman says that,
but what we just talked about here clearly contradicts.
So it's important for you to we bring this up specifically so that you can
help your students navigate some of these things, because these are not
obscure authors and people that you never hear of.
These are mainstream people in the media that are on TV sometimes that are
often featured during like National Geographic and Discovery Channel kinds
of specials where your students may come across them in the future.
And we want you to be aware so you can help make them aware to be able to say,
well, you know what, look at these kinds of comments critically so that they
understand that just because someone like this says this, that doesn't
necessarily make that true and they want to make sure that they dive
into the actual evidence.
If you read on what Bart Ehrman says, super smart guy,
but doesn't really back comments like this up with a whole bunch of evidence.
One resource that I do want to point out is Jonathan Marl wrote an excellent
book called Questioning the Bible, 11 major challenges to the Bible's
authority and suggested resource inside the leaders guide.
So I would suggest that you you pick that up yourself,
but that book is designed specifically to speak to your students.
So if your students have questions about this topic specifically,
they're just stuck and you need to move on or or they just want to know more,
encourage them or maybe you just buy it for them, get this book and have them
read through it and then set up a different discussion on that book
specifically and it'll be a tremendous resource for them.
So if we're getting what we believe from the Bible,
then we better be sure what the Bible says is saying it accurately.
And although it may seem we have, you know,
thousands of different kinds of translations and we have so many copies.
The Bible is the best selling book in the history of the world.
It's been copied so many times over and over and over and over again.
And there are lots of people that are trying to discredit it.
But when you continue to look at the evidence,
the Bible continues to prove itself as something that has been transmitted
over the course of history accurately and reliably to what was actually
recorded originally.
So what Paul, so you can be confident,
you can and you can remind your students as you sit in small group and
encourage them and help them understand that what Paul wrote and what Jesus said
is actually what Paul wrote and what Jesus said.
Now, that has incredible consequences, right?
Either we listen to what Paul says and what Jesus says and what Peter says and what
went on and the gospel and the Old Testament and all that's going on in here.
Or we don't, but we can't assume that this is inaccurate.
So as you're getting into your small groups,
talk with your students about, OK, so now that they understand that there's a
reliability to this and we're going to get even more into it in the next couple
of weeks here, but start to poke a little bit at them and say, you know,
well, what's this going to mean down the road?
What's this going to mean today?
What's this going to mean tomorrow and next week in the next couple of weeks?
The more you discover about the importance of this book,
what is that going to mean for your life?
Because the more you know about this, unless you can ignore it.